il est présent
pour ça vous sur sexuelle pour parler de
mircale efficace de l'église s'arrêter
plusieurs nouveaux scandales d'abus
sexuels de prêtres ont fait la manchette
en travaux et recherches au plus près
300 prêtres abuseurs en pennsylvanie
aussi ce sont 34 avec des missions
québec qui va rendre des comptes pour
une série d'agressions commises par des
pères oblats dans plusieurs villages de
la mauricie et de la côte-nord
pourquoi les houblons dans toutes les
réserves
tu as poneys dans le monde c'est à
croire que les les ils savaient pas où
le suspense l'épaule et aux lauréats
lors de village en village
anne panassac et soigne a démarré ont
recueilli des témoignages bouleversants
il ya basta play com assassiné il ya les
fabristes h endroit exprès pour abuser
il nous fallait par la grange et tout de
suite ça mais descend durable alors
qu'on a tenté trop longtemps d'étouffer
ce scandale ce soir on met des noms et
des visages aux agresseurs et on vous
parle de l'enfer des victimes dont
plusieurs zones qui en parle pour la
première fois je vais vivre avec des
séquelles
[Musique]
bienvenue à enquête
[Applaudissements]
c'est passé à l'église des choses pas
très catholiques avec nos curés les
audois font partie de l'histoire du
québec
leur grande mission était d'évangéliser
les autochtones voir les civilisés il
régnait littéralement sur les âmes et
les corps il disait ce qui se posent à
l'église reste à l'église j'étais des
années notre enquête nous amener chez
deux nations huit communautés d'un
village à l'autre
nous avons découvert l'existence de
prêtres abuseurs en quelques semaines
nous avons pu documenter les agressions
sexuelles commises parc 10 oblats après
15 à suspense que et ce tant qu'on sent
qu'on rencontre sont plus le temps qu'on
me donne lumia surnommé au cours des
années plusieurs autochtones ont dénoncé
les agressions sexuelles mais en vain
les autorités religieuses ont fait la
sourde oreille
je vais le dire le cheveu c'est chez
vous ne sortez pas le bonhomme node nord
je vais vous avez peu près ça me fait
rien demain matin fred page des journaux
cette déclaration alors ils l'ont sorti
tout de suite ayons bien faire selon
prix puis de l'envoyer l'anneau
les demandes à l'aide des missionnaires
eux mêmes à leurs congrégations restent
lettre morte
ainsi le père couture un pédophile à
wemotaci et laissé seul à régler ses
démons comme un produit purement ravages
et puis j'en avais parlé plus mayor que
cette page est un problème réglé
l'église a laissé les enfants
autochtones sans défense le seul
communauté à ma connaissance non jamais
promené début reste la communauté des
six pitt
parce qu'ils n'ont jamais eu cure et
quévy très bas pas de cris pas de
problème voilà
[Musique]
nous sommes à wemotaci en haute mauricie
chez les attikameks le terrain de jeu du
père couture simaga bas qui ont fait un
peu bizarre
voilà la liste aussi proche de la
cabanasse que ça s'est déroulé
alex nous amène là où le curry l'a
agressé alors qu'il était un gamin
cela se passait dans les années 80 ça
s'est passé là-bas la mer en bleu à pois
bleus l'ont ils n'avaient que 6 and the
bad points
de ce parcours
jayson est aujourd'hui directeur du
service des incendies
à son retour d'études il est choqué par
ce qu'il attend je m'attendais à
éteindre des feux j'ai ramassé plus de
cadeaux c'est d'avoir j'ai même pas 7
doit se maintenir un compte au nom des
victimes contre la chine par des zombies
quelqu'un qui a une balle quant à elle
pour beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à cause
du père coutume entre autres c'étaient
des amis prennent à une couture
missionnaires oblats s'en est pris à une
douzaine de garçons de la communauté
j'aurais 11 et 12 ans et je ne vous
réussit à l'église j'étais avec un autre
garçon du même âge ils nous avaient
invités d'aller à la cueillette des
framboises produit plus au large
l'eau qui a choisi de devenir vu la
compagnie
couture savait comment attirer les
petits garçons c'est probablement la
seule personne au village tel un zoo
il nous laissait pas de son camion
c'était quelqu'un qui savait tout faire
reculer de main devenus à un site où il
s'est tu
mr dom et sedar alex sait depuis
longtemps qu arthur a aussi été victime
du père couture mais c'est la première
fois que les deux partagent leur
histoire
à deux ils trouvent le courage de
confronter le passé et de revoir avec
nous les chalets utilisé par le
missionnaire pour piéger ses proies dans
sa valeur n'est pas là pas vraiment
vraiment petit bonhomme là de faire ça
fait rêver
puis il m'avait déjà fait
seul à bord c'est jusqu'à ce qu'il
mérite je subis soit à deux pistes
puis quitté à 8 allergan il va être
poussée lippi là-bas cela commence à
signer l'avenant - une pointe à la 17ème
étape tranquille ça il le dit souvent ce
lundi soir
afin d'anticiper à eau en retire ce
possible parrot 17 bien encore la colère
tout ce que je vais attendre et comment
les jeunes ont été et
les rumeurs d'agressions parviennent par
charles coucou aux pères spirituels à
wemotaci
il confronte alors rénale couture
publiquement au magasin communautaires
tout fait qui m'a dit si vous ne voulez
pas de moi je sais pas répondu
[Musique]
la brute passée parce qu'on a besoin ce
que vous pourrez toucher mais c'est
parti le jeu comporte ce sont les aînés
les mouches mais l'icône qu'ils ont
retenu les mouches hommes cocon c'est
comme avec d occulter la communauté ce
qui a réduit les jeunes au silence c'est
nos grands-parents incidents dans notre
communauté était tellement pour l'église
tellement incroyable
plusieurs d'entre eux ne seraient pas
réunis jeudi de pièces pour moi j'ai
gardé ça va dans 21 ans temps
21 21 arthur lui a d'abord mis cela en
chansons
j'ai rencontré un enfant qui marchait
chante-t-il je vais te dire ce qui
m'arrive
ce qu'on m'a fait subir je voulais
mourir à cause des torts parce qu'elle
me trouverai je me sauvais dégueulasse
[Musique]
pardon si le terme arabe et c'est tout
le temps de les classes comme appât
haute pas de maraude
le premier vol du mobile
c'était la bo presbytère
[Musique]
il m'avait dit la veille tiendra demain
matin tout seul mais l'embarras
camarades du parti sont tous là explique
allure si je n'ai jamais pensé même pas
ça déjà pas demain la hausse ou soit il
y avait une chance
que
la voici sept chambres pour moi serait
facile pour ce lot mais je pense qu'ils
avaient déjà il y avait fabriqué sa
chambre expert pour pouvoir abuser il
faut se coucher intitulé dix ans a passé
la barre caisses ne rompez avec la sec
en tête 7 8 a peut-être plus jeunes ce
pont est utilisé la force
ouais ah oui le poignet pas eu si peu
timide au panier du panier et ou encore
comme ça et ça marchait pour consoles
combat et nous celle avec six rangs où
il ya plein d'enfants
une décennie d'abus des victimes se
suicide
et comble d'insultés de vigny qui
célèbre les funérailles dans ce cas
c'est lui-même célébrer des messes très
particules
mais que lui josy fait le service fut
même c'est quoi qui avait dans sa tête
c'est qu'est ce qui revient à sa tête
son pur pour la question
c'est justement le suicide d'un protège
et qui pousse la travailleuse sociale à
confronter missionnaire cherchait qu est
ce que tu as fait signer et là il m'a
ouvert la pâte puis matinée d'un coup il
m'a fait ça demain
fin 80 avec d'autres intervenantes
elle demande aux autorités religieuses
de retirer le père couture de wemotaci
illégaux ils voulaient pas porter
plainte et mâcon peuvent lfs artic cl
j'ai joint rénale de couture ou
téléphone à la maison de retraite des
oblats richelieu il reconnaît avoir
commis des abus
pour ce jeu avec les enfants il affirme
avoir demandé de l'aide
pendant ses missions notamment aux
psychologues des oblats la communauté
c'est à dire la congrégation des oblats
de marie immaculée a réagi seulement
lorsque les zébus risquait d'être rendue
publique et que fait-elle alors elle le
cache en france mais il sera rattrapé
quelques années plus tard nous y
reviendrons
après la pause on poursuit notre enquête
dans un village où les enfants est
agressé de génération en génération par
les curés qui s'y sont succédé
[Musique]
les all blacks sont présents chez les
attikameks depuis le début du 20e siècle
surtout à manawan où on tente de les
sédentariser plusieurs missionnaires ils
sont passés au fil des ans mais 3
d'entre eux ont marqué à jamais les
attikameks ils ont agressé sexuellement
femme ou enfant de trois générations
différentes
les souvenirs de madeleine et d'antoine
remonte aux années 50 un bon coup je
vous adore avec mes amis de ma grand
mère m'a appelé en me disant vas
chercher de l'argent tu vas acheter un
médaillon chez le prêtre mais rendue au
presbytère les choses tournent autre nom
elle s'est méritée le bret était en
train de se bercer était complètement dû
s'élever venu directement vers les
caisses qui voulaient de vous il m'a
aidé et j'ai pas dit quel âge sans cesse
à 25 ans il m'avait retenu les portes
d'autres jeux cette indemnité pas que
juste attitude il faisait pas touché non
moi j'espère qu'ils chantent minutes
avec son pénis
[Musique]
le curé en question c'est édouard mayer
un haut blanc qui a desservi manawan de
1938 à 53 il l'était exhibitionniste me
racontent les aînés et tripotait les
enfants fillette aux garçons gta pour
que ça colle à la confesse et glissé sa
main sous une robe pour toucher nos
fesses mais vous avez gardé le silence
des atermoiements comme un certain
monsieur vu cinq cuves
ça tue maintenant troublant d'entendre
des femmes et des hommes devenus grands
parents en parler pour la première fois
antonio aussi a décidé de se libérer du
secret religieux même confessé avec mon
petit frère et le père lui a montré ses
partisans à 8,1 pro l'aide à tenir
il versait gresset des filles qui est ce
qu'on fait c'est ma femme et sa soeur
kate elle est sortie la ds à sare tard
et jamais dû me laisser seul m'amuser
complètement son jeu suivant
[Musique]
claude et son petit neveu quarante ans
plus tard
lui aussi a été agressé par une aube là
cette fois c'est clément couture on dit
que mon bien sont très religieux
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je crois
que c'est l'ancien directeur du
pensionnat à pointe bleue au lac saint
jean
lorsque l'école a fermé les oblats n'ont
envoyé à manawan
il y est resté jusqu'en 1996 avait
demandé d'y aller cette origine mais
cela quant à lui mettre le paddock
on m'a fait des attouchements tu as quel
âge je veux c'est un n'y a pas voulu
macrom à g a forcé quand j'ai parlé de
ça elle disait la lie au coin d'aller
prier parce que c'était un péché de
parler de m
sa grand-mère préparer les repas du curé
et c'est claude qui devait aller les lui
porter à les porter dans tous les jours
ce qu'ils touchaient tous les jours je
vais deux fois par semaine jean les
conséquences sont tragiques pour lui
quand il m'écoutait pas moi je me je me
coupais ici vos vols pour faire mais
cette flamme alors bien mal neige mais
cette année l'homme j'ai passé une année
semée par un tombé dans la drogue où
nous sommes je me sentais mal la plus
folle qu'est ce que tu as trouvé le plus
évolué chacun
quand qu'on m'a jamais écouté c'est ça
n'était pas cru je devais te ouais
pourquoi me fut
de toutes les histoires entendues chez
les attikameks celle concernant le père
jean marc houle est la plus
déconcertante
cela se passe dans les années 60 70
adrienne nous raconte le rituel du
prêtre il dit c'est le dimanche 17
semaines lors toutes les femmes
enceintes là vont venir au presbytère
c'est l'autre leur cellule 5 sur toutes
les parties du corps oui je le vends sur
les seins les parties génitales ou si je
crois que vous madeleine seul effet
faire une fois il va le mettre dans hama
ce qui nous faisait allongé sur le lit
et nous disaient de fermer les yeux
puis il frottait notre vente avec de
l'huile sainte center le jeune chef de
manawan fait appel à max gros-louis
alors leader de l'association des aînés
du québec
il est une figure mythique des luttes
autochtone max gros louis a vieilli mais
il est toujours vif d'esprit il se
souvient très bien sa rencontre avec une
des femmes le curé mauffette des croix
sur lui ça y voit un peu partout sur le
vin des croix sur mon parti et moi
coucher tôt
puis il me disait que c'était pour
enlever le diable dans l'enfant qui va
naître à lormes en sortant de là la
première chose que j'ai fait j'ai ali a
lâché verge et puis j'avais à dire le
cheveu c'est si vous ne sortez pas bonne
au mode lan puisez vous n'avez pas trop
ça me fait rien demain matin frontpage
des journaux cette déclaration alors ils
l'ont sorti tout de suite et y ont bien
fait ça ils l'ont pris puis de l'envoyer
d'un autre
ap s'invite sur la côte nord chez les
innus nous allons y est l'une aussi pour
connaître la suite des choses
[Musique]
dans les années 70
l'église règne sans conteste dans les
communautés innus de la côte-nord donné
le canada aux oblats de marie immaculée
un ordre créé en france il ya 200 ans
les premiers missionnaires sont arrivés
au pays en 1841 avec comme devoir de
christianiser les autochtones et cela
commence avec les enfants et les
pensionnats les houblons impose le
catholicisme et un silence religieux
c'est dans ce contexte que robert
dominique à l'époque ni lui apprendre
ses ennemis attikameks qui est le berre
houle qui arrive de manawan
est-ce que vous avez averti la
population de ce que vous savez non pas
du tout au détour des aînés dans une
croyance a agréé les autres la religion
elle aussi sacrée raclée en 70 s p dit
qu'un curé qui violent des petites
filles il flatte des cailloux qui est où
il fait des choses vous étiez 3
capdevielle plus le droit d'aller nulle
part objets tibet libre et gtx comme il
y est
le père houle ne semble pas avoir commis
d'abus sexuels durant son bref mandat
pessimiste mais notre enquête sur lui a
permis de déterrer plusieurs autres cas
de curé abuseurs ici je sais que les
hommes sur terre c'est s'épauler sont
pas très catholique par goutte et
surtout les curés rachel et la soeur de
robert
elle a été agressée par trois curés à
pessamit dès l'âge de 7 ans oui 3 tous
des oblats le faire le singe il ne
mentait des hôtels avait sept ans
j'étais toujours à bien petite robe mais
ils nous mentent et les l'hérault pin il
nous faisait mettre debout puis nous
pencher oui en avant on a pensé comme
selon le même puis prenez des photos
mais oui nous prenez des photos puis des
fois il pensait son petit doigt
[Musique]
silvio lesage le curé photographe a
laissé sa marque sur d'autres femmes
après lui roméo archambault par h en
bout il m'a amené une fois dans la lah
l'endroit secrète
c'est dans le couloir noir puis c'est à
peu près 5 6 pieds de l'ass et c'est
moussa un au sous-sol de l'église pire
était derrière moi
puis là j'avais senti son chose en
arrière puis me prenais part les petits
seins puis après ça me il fallait que je
fasse seul martyr dans un endroit noir
comme j'ai des attikameks tout ce passe
dans la noirceur des sous sols comme ici
alors que l'église elle baigne dans la
lumière divine
moi je me suis sentie brisé d'être
vraiment d'immigrés dénigrer de ces
petits riens pas bonne une peau bonne là
un vaurien même aujourd'hui il ya des
boîtes que je me sens demain c'est la
loge wes la loge jean-yves nous invite à
son meta chan là où il pratique le rite
ancien de l'attentât suri longtemps
interdit par l'église me semble vraiment
simple je suis et je pose des journées
c'est au seul des fois à méditer à prier
un lieu intime pour parler de ce que lui
a fait le curé romeo archambault le même
qui agressait rachel archambault la
première fois et moi fait de quoi
etaient-ce automne
[Musique]
c'est après la messe tout ça est venu me
féliciter que j'avais écrite et bien
jean yves servais la messe pour 10 ou
par service ils m'ont compris par
derrière de main dans les faits ce qui
part après c'était sérieux comme un
cauchemar un pet remplace l'autre il ici
vi se poursuivre
voilà première fois par la pointer il
m'a poliment venu dans la loge
mais moi plaqué dans l'armure tout de
suite ça mais descend durable j'ai pu me
défaire de ses sorties elle s'étoffe
empareront non de trop à peu près
c'était la sacristie il y avait une
garde-robe ou ce qu'ils avaient les sous
tend toute seule piquante ont été selon
ses habiles c'est l'eau qui veulent
ouvre une soutane on l'a enlevé à puis
on voyait pas la personne arrive par
derrière sans j'avais pas quand
j'arrivais lasota j'avais tout un tas
jean-yves se confie à son grand père mal
lui en a pris
belle image une fessée en plus fallait
que j'aille à confesse me confesser
d'avoir blasphémé inverse de curel
auprès de la pointe lui-même joué le
père rené lapointe
on se fait été envoyé à natashquan il va
y rester trente ans son influence se
fait encore sentir
arrivé à natashquan je sens que la
communauté est divisée ceux qui
voudraient me parlent et se disent
intimider par les fidèles de la pointe
c'est seulement derrière les portes que
victime ou témoin me raconte que le curé
paient des petits garçons pour le
masturber j'ai vu le curé nu avec 2 afin
de me disant qu'ils ne masturber avec
peu d'argent sur son bureau pour le
payer une victime me confirme avoir été
payé pour cela
dans les années 80 km l'argent pour ça
vias grimpé à ce qu'un jugement eynden
en 2003 là est ce qu'une enquête à la
suite d'une plainte
elle appelle germaine aujourd'hui
travailleuse sociale pour qu elle
raconte comment elle était tombée sur le
curry nu au presbytère en compagnie d'un
petit garçon est un enfant qui avait
environ entre 8 et 10 ans je me dis
qu'est ce que tu fais ici toi j'ai dit
hier on le prête dans sa chambre j'ai
dit ok je mens beige quand on a sa
chance je remplis je vois le père
lapointe qui était assis comme un
cow-boy sceller les pattes comme ça sur
son bureau sa secrétaire qui avait une
petite servir autant de de sa part il y
avait les fascine au couteau nous il n'y
a pas eu d'accusations criminelles
le père lapointe décide de rester avec
l'appui des aînés mais deux ans plus
tard le supérieur des oblats et l'évêque
de rimouski vienne le chercher
joint au téléphone dans sa résidence de
retraite
le père lapointe nie toute agression
ce que vous dites l'invendable
absolument rien de vrai là tout ça rien
de vrai désastre
ils étaient prêts à nous donner une
entrevue à la caméra mais le père
provincial le supérieur des oblats a
donné la directive à tous de ne pas
parler aux journalistes
après de multiples tentatives de le
rejoindre par courriel par téléphone sur
place également le père luc tardif a
refusé par courriel de nous accorder une
entrevue ou à chaque malioténam une
autre communauté ea nous un nom autre
missionnaire troubles une autre plainte
ignorer
non on a décidé d'aller à boire là avec
amour les flashbacks lot était présente
dans la salle
c'est là qu'on a présenté nos
revendications concernant ma part aucun
des deux candidats n'a communiqué
c'était en 1970 les vieux de la
communauté avait délégué des jeunes pour
rencontrer l'évêque et se plaindre du
comportement du missionnaire au maire
provencher avec les femmes et les
fillettes
les jeunes d'alors ont vieilli gérard a
fait un avc
mais les deux se souviennent avec
amertume de leur mandat il vous a plu
non
provencher est donc resté et à continuer
à terroriser des fillettes pendant des
années ils donnaient des lifts à la
sortie de la messe comme le raconte
annette lauréats commences à te prenais
la pluie à la file la bouche et qui a
rédigé par jean louis le voyez ça m'aide
à mieux faire moins une fois et demie
celle là je ne sais pas par la porte
jallet audard et la liberté
d'association
d'autres femmes ont affirmé avoir subi
des agressions beaucoup plus sérieuse de
ce curé
au maire provencher est finalement parti
vivre à québec avec une famille nous
rejoint au téléphone il ne veut pas
parler pas avant d'être accusé dit il
encore une fois les autorités
religieuses ont été avertis une fois de
plus elles ont laissé faire
[Musique]
après la pause un prêtre agresseur est
dénoncé par sa propre nièce qui dévoile
des lettres incriminantes
[Musique]
la prise de parole a commencé ici à
maliotenam aux audiences de l' enquête
sur les femmes autochtones disparues ou
assassinées
j'avais 7 ans
[Musique]
le curé venait souvent chez nous il a
commencé à me caresser partout jusque
dans mes fesses les dénonciations
pleuvent
alexis joveneau aurait agressé de
nombreuses personnes pendant des
décennies dans deux communautés zimu de
la basse-côte-nord benguela d'un autre
côté t elle tenir à dire comment ça a
touché à me caresser le vent et parle à
7,1 me touche vers le bas le courage de
ces familles nous s est la nièce même
deux genoux en parle et qui tout de
suite ni un commentaire sur radio canada
pour leur dire que confirmer le
témoignage des femmes
inouï que moi même aussi j'avais été
abusée pendant neuf mois sur la réserve
à la fin de ses études en belgique en
1981 elle rejoint aidé son oncle c'était
la découverte de ce tome et ceux de
vivre
enfer au quotidien toutes les nuits
c'est vraiment été une horreur ce qui me
faisait c'était une horreur
c'était un grand alcoolique et l'enfer
commencé le soir pour moi la journée il
était plutôt calme mais le soir mais
invitait dans ce qu'on appelle nous
fallait il nous appelle ça la chambre
noire dans son petit salon qui donnait
qui avait axé sur sa chambre donc il me
demandait de lui apporter des jeans
orange et je savais que l'enfer allait
commencer elle finit par s'enfuir
son oncle la relance par lettre une
centaine de pages qu'elle me remets
comme preuve
en voici un extrait ce qui n'empêche pas
mon coeur de se mettre au bout de mes
doigts et de caresser les cuisses en te
disant que j'aime leur douceur ni
demeurait c'est les yeux un admirant
leurs courbes de sortie de petite voix
intérieure en moyenne site il faut qu'il
faut que je vienne il faut que je fasse
une entrevue et que j'amène les lettres
comme preuve écrite parce que c'est
vraiment une preuve elle nous dirigent
vers francis marque en innu de unamen
shipu le fief de georges nous nous le
rencontrons à québec où ils seraient
traitées pour un cancer du pancréas
sexuellement actives mais cette ruelle à
17 ans francis travail pour le curry
pour illustrer les livres de catéchèse
traduit en innu télé chez betfair et
montceau m'embrassait navale de fabre
bien un moment d'annoncer je lui fait
une pub pour le satisfaire
j'avais jusque dans leurs du perdu
connaissance et je pense que le bon dieu
est fauché mais le dirige jarry
aujourd'hui parce que c'est celle que
j'ai pensé que j'étais jeune
tu as vraiment en ce sens oui un moment
donné j'étais plein direct on dit oui
j'ai dit je vais me confesser à mon fief
picto facto je voulais fait pas de fil
agression lévesque sautonne qu'est ce
qui te dit emma les fûts m'apporte vidéo
c'est quoi la justice et non aucun
monseigneur sothen un oubli en ensuite
été nommé archevêque et les décédés en
2015 en emportant avec lui les
confidences de victimes
c'est la mort de genou qui a mis fin au
supplice de francis qui aura durée de
six à sept ans
ce n'est qu'à l' enquête nationale
lorsque tout a été rendu public que la
congrégation des oblats de marie
immaculée a émis un communiqué les
oblats sont profondément préoccupés
l'iaaf ligier suite aux témoignages
entendus écrit-elle joe venons et
enterré chez les innu où il est question
de l'exil me et renvoyer les ossements
aux obla à meung ans dans un autre
cimetière innu l'aube la rolande alone
et surveille aussi ses fidèles simon
d'or pour l'éternité a coûté son abuseur
tellement neveu préféré
alors je te dis repose un paiement ces
six mois je t'aime simon avait confié
son histoire à sa tante mais elle a
obligé à garder le secret pendant des
années dumas avait laissé une grosse
responsabilité
ça m'a soulagé de révéler son secret
aujourd'hui elle révèle l'ampleur des
agressions subies alors qu'il n'était
qu'un enfant
c'était la nuit quand tu es allé
rejoindre son domicile
cela a commencé au pensionnat où le père
de l'eau n'est enseignée en 1967 il est
nommé curé à bainghen equani cheap comme
disent les ennemis il ya eu l'audace de
nous suivre jusqu ici jeudi luis avec
elle qui abusé des enfants
mais pourquoi tu es venu jusqu'ici pour
continuer qu'est-ce qui avec un masque
incapable de vivre dans le même village
que son abuseur symonds quittent mingant
dès la fin du secondaire pour la grande
ville et l'oubli artificiel
la violence sexuelle du père de l'oni
c'est avec jean-marc jourdain que nous
en prenons toute la mesure
le bun le un lieu beaucoup c'est un
homme brisé par ses multiples tentatives
de suicide
coco chanel et lui malu malu malu malgré
sa détresse jean-marc comme tous les
autres tenait à se libérer de son
fardeau et dénoncer ceux qui ont régné
sur leur âme et leur corps et c'est
grâce à ces témoignages que notre
enquête a débusqué 10 oblats abuseurs
regardez ces photos d'époque n'importe
laquelle il ya toujours la moitié
d'entre eux qui sont dénoncés pour leur
agression sexuelle sur des enfants qui
nous est ce qu'avec des prêtres qui ont
bénéficié de la protection leur
congrégation
souvent goût de père rénale couture kate
et cachés en france par ses supérieurs
c'était avant que huit garçons de
wemotaci ne portent finalement plainte à
la police
c'est le seul des dix obus leur avoir
été poursuivi en 2004 il est condamné à
15 mois de prison
moi j'appelle ça une sentence bonbon
céline trop keane mais plus que tout ce
qui a incité jean a parlé publiquement
avoir été victime ce qui t'avait le
subaru jeu très jeunes enfants sans
défense
chez lui au fait du mal absolu à partir
alex et arthur étaient deux des
plaignants jusqu'à ce jour leur usage et
même leurs noms étaient cachés par ordre
de la cour
il tenait à raconter leurs histoires à
visage découvert je veux vivre avec ce
qu'elle en tout
la voltige mais parle d'un homme je n'ai
pas le donnent comme on a en france
qu'elle juge utiles pour qu est ce que j
ai subi des enfants sans défense
marquée à vie
en quittant wemotaci charles coucou
lesage nous apprend que enfants en est
du québec se dit petites lumières pour
acter le magnifique telma glisse unia
petites lumières et les curés
mc haute cour est et le mot curé flamme
noir je ne s'invente pas c'est pas moi
mais la plante noir ils l'ont dit lui
éteint le feu des petites ailes de
lumière il suffit qu'on l'appelle revue
people
les abus sexuels
[Musique]
en terminant deux éléments sujet notre
enquête de ce soir d'abord vous dire
qu'une demande de recours collectif a
été déposée contre les pères oblats dans
cette affaire et ensuite que notre
collègue anne palacio qui vous le savez
enquête depuis des années sur ce qui se
passe dans les communautés autochtones
ont préparé un balado fascinant où vous
allez pouvoir entrer dans les coulisses
de notre travail d'enquêté
c'est tout pour ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
et revenez nous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]